I'm gonna be doing some relationship
coaching and matchmaking with the help
of Astro fashionista zodiac guru we're
gonna find some love based on zodiac
sign yeah and hopefully we'll be back
for a wedding later my dating lifestyle
is basically non-existent I came out two
years ago and I grew up in the Midwest
and I've had a girlfriend before but
I've never dated a guy before in my
dating life I've encountered a lot of
virgos it's like I'm a Virgo magnet I
want to build an empire with somebody
somebody was compassionate kind loving
crazy but also can philosophize about I
don't know the ever-expanding universe
so the daters are gonna take the spicy
assessment which stands for self
passion intimacy communication and
learning to say yes with this assessment
I'm gonna be able to dive in deeper into
their interpersonal development and
where we need to strengthen so that I
can help them find the perfect match and
then I'm gonna look at their natal chart
look at their love planets and then make
my perfect zodiac recommendation too
spicy and so we can find them the best
match I'm just gonna try to answer these
as honestly as possible I have standards
and ideals in my mind about what I
expected relationship to look like yeah
my fear of rejection makes it difficult
for me to provide self exposure in a
relationship ooh that is really personal
sexual chemistry is important to you in
a relationship strongly strongly
strongly strongly strongly agree with
that because sex is important and I feel
like this is almost like a therapy
session during my childhood my parents
shared their opinions and permitted me
to share mine I mean I feel like I'm
about to have a breakdown I feel like
I'm ready to date now because there were
some questions here that I had never
even thought to ask based on what the
daters told me I decided that I was
gonna really take into account what they
need personality types that would be a
good balance but I also wanted to
challenge them a little bit Nicco in
particular she has a great energy and
she's passionate about life she said no
Virgo so guess who I decided to set her
up with I'm Cooper James I'm a Virgo and
my personality's probably described in
three words that's raw positive
energy I'm extremely confident that I
will be that one Virgo that changes all
past perceptions of virgos and sweeps it
right off her feet so Tamara is a double
Virgo but she has a Scorpio moon which
means she's really intense and not so
easy to get to know he has a strong
sexual appetite so we knew that a
Scorpio would be perfect for her and
Tyler is extremely beautiful and would
be able to hold Tamra's attention
probably describe myself to be fun for
sure a little bit goofy but shy it's so
hard finding like a genuine person I
just wanted somebody to keep it real
with me so Ryan's a Gemini and we
thought he could probably only do well
with another Gemini but then we thought
of Curley who's actually a Virgo and a
lot of people don't know but Virgo and
Jim and I have the same sign ruler
mercury the communication planet really
had a lot of relationship experience
he's also extremely fun and charismatic
I'm basically just looking for someone
to join me along in my journey almost
like a condiment to like my burger you
know something a little extra I'm
excited to find love but you know who
are we kidding I'm also excited to find
a little bit of dick you know it's up to
them now to make sure that this lasts
longer than just one date I set up this
lunch date for me in Tamara we're gonna
be making some cucumber martinis and one
of my favorite desserts
and then you do that theme words like
hug or a hand but she was down to hug so
I was like cool cuz I'm a hugger awesome
we're off to a good start today we're
gonna be painting portraits of each
other and I think they're having a
little bit of wine and a little bit of
paint will help loosen him up a little
bit I've never been on a date you've
never been a big no-no Cheers
yes just oh that was looks like that
already no you're fine
some super said to be Miku today she's
my blind date and I planned this really
cool date for us to do it's gonna take
place in this main studio that I rented
out just for us I was maybe a little bit
intimidated because I was like is he
gonna kick my ass right now did I walk
into a training session or a blind day
I'm not really sure all right let's make
a double let's get the nut you dirty
laundry I don't drink so I was like oh
man I can't partake and let's make you a
virgin because I'm service yeah right
I'm trying to get your impeccable style
down uh-huh that's gonna be the hardest
part
you still like be really big on dating
guys that style and now I'm like no
really well I'm just kind of like yeah I
don't care like now I'm like I just want
somebody with the big credit score who
can make me laugh surprises the point I
set up a photo shoot for us all right so
I'm gonna go like this right you're
gonna come behind me you're gonna like
lean on we started making these her face
at one point she put like cream in my
mouth which I thought was like cute
all we need is a I feel like they were
setting us up for something else because
of the strawberries those whipped cream
and chocolate syrup three things that
lead to something else it's kind of like
a broken heart
no but it's not broken heart I was
trying to make more of a like in I mean
look this heart I am okay with that so
are you ready to see our paintings I am
I hope you like this I think I'm gonna
like mine say I've never seen a purely
responded really well and it honestly
ended up being this really fun time he
knew what he was doing especially cuz he
lifted me up in the air and I trusted
him not to kill me so my job was to
introduce a new burger and it was a
Virgo though I did not expect that I
would absolutely go on another date with
Miku if she would have me seeing as I'm
a Virgo I feel like I would probably
like break his heart like he seemed too
sweet and too nice and I would have like
I'm like a black widow I would have
destroyed him I need a bad [ __ ]
you know no I mean the vibe was
definitely fun funny exciting intimate
it's cool she's good about like body
language she made me feel comfortable we
have fun
[Music]
yes so maybe I didn't find true love but
this experience has taught me to stay
more open or that I am more open to
letting somebody ask me out which I mean
hey I'm available Dana was such a risk
and it's just worth it I feel like no
matter what you were worried about just
just take that chance I'm glad that I
took a risk here and open it up to
someone and had them open up to me I'm
not big on going on blind dates so this
was a little out of my comfort zone but
I'm really glad I did it
it was a super adventurous date and I
had a lot of fun so I can't complain I
mean I'm actually gonna hang out with
him after this so I don't know if that
tells you anything don't hate virgos
[Music]
[Music]